at the price per kilo it is the most
expensive lemon in the world on the market you can
find the caviar lemon around
200,300 euros per kilo it is a lemon that
is rare and that you cannot find everywhere
on supermarket shelves
[Music]
my name and detain heat and I'm
perrine schaller it's been ten
years since with etienne we've been together we
were the first to grow lemon
caviar in france for the sale of fruit
in the lemon caviar is a fruit to  these
little English people also call it
finger lime so it has a shape a
little like two fingers like that
and inside there are only small
balls in the lemon caviar finally takes its
name from the shape of the small
balls  that we find inside the
swing caviar which looks like the eyes of
the sturgeon is bi are really
perfectly round and the flavor of the sites
involved is very very very
interesting there can be different
tastes depending on the varieties of the
maturities it can  there  ler of the very acid
lemon
with the perfume of lemongrass also which
presents in certain lemon caviar
[Music]
the village from where it is very important
for our exploitation because the
rate of sunshine and 320 days of
sunshine per year will therefore allow
citrus fruits to grow in their maturity
below 300 days of sunshine per
year citrus fruits we forget
this lemon and so expensive because it is a
lemon which is sold in very small
quantities also trees which are also
not very productive
which is very hard  physically there are a
lot of losses on the trees too
and a lot of fruit that is not
picked up and it is quite full we are
constantly surprised by the fruit
that we obtain
it is a lemon that is actually prized by the
great chefs today  Today
we work with approximately 25
three-star restaurants in France,
perhaps a little more.
because
we bring them the colors and they
will do the painting behind
hello I am daniel lectern chef de
cuisine have spent two restaurants 34000
montpellier and salt for eight years
I like his lemons because it is a
concentrate of acidity  concentrate of
modernity
and at the same time it brings an elegance
to the dish because it is not too
lively it's just me where you put 4 bis
under your defense that the lemon and
exploded today I cook you a
pie  fine mustard macro flames
and and lemon caviar when I introduce it
into a dish it is one of the
central elements it is it which will wake up the
graffiti is that the most important then it
brings this question to the customer in
fact there is  this acidity which will not be
and then they will bring the rest it
moves that's where we have to do without
haute cuisine makes people dream
lemon caviar is an element of
gastronomy and not ultimately sacred
desire for the inaccessible  in fact of a
go get them
[Music]